quinientos sesenta y seis días después
el expresidente donald trump volvió a
dar un mitin en washington la capital
estadounidense
lo hizo invitado a una cumbre de la
américas first policy institute centro
de pensamiento que está preparando le la
nueva agenda política trump apeló a la
ley y orden al desmoronamiento del país
y volvió a recurrir a mentiras como sus
denuncias de fraude en las elecciones de
2020 ahora siempre digo que me presenté
la primera vez y gane luego me postulé
por segunda vez y lo hice el nuevo
obtuvimos millones y millones de votos
más y sabes que esa será la historia por
mucho tiempo fue una desgracia pero es
posible que tengamos que hacerlo de
nuevo antes
sin confirmarlo todavía dio pistas de su
postulación para 2024 enfrente podría
tener a un viejo amigo su
exvicepresidente mike pence que volvió a
washington el mismo día para un mitin es
la segunda ocasión en la que se
contraprograman después de arizona pence
fue invitado por otro grupo conservador
el ya una america's fundation y pidió a
los republicanos dejar de mirar a las
denuncias de fraude electoral para que
no vino y para mirar hacia atrás sino
para mirar hacia adelante la verdad es
que ahora más que nunca los
conservadores deben concentrarse en los
desafíos que enfrentan los
estadounidenses y ofrecer una agenda
audaz y positiva de soluciones para el
futuro
howse de verdad
solo
un comité parlamentario ha aprobado
otras ocho sesiones que trump presión a
penas para no certificar el triunfo del
demócrata joe biden después el 6 de
enero cuando se produjo el asalto al
capitolio trump señaló a pensé en un
tuit lo puso en peligro ante la turba
violenta y ahora podría pasar a ser su
principal rival